I think anyone who watches number files
really likely to be familiar with the
name John Conway he's a really famous
mathematician a really interesting
character and we've even featured him a
couple of times here on the channel I'm
not going to worry anymore ever again
but here's some interesting news there's
a new biography of Conway out it's
called genius at play by Siobhan Roberts
I'll tell you a bit more about the book
later but first of all I want to show
you a video because Siobhan and some
people she's been working with while
writing the book made a short little
kind of film or mini documentary with
John Conway and they've decided to give
it its first viewing here on numberphile
so I'm going to play that film and then
I'll talk to you again afterwards
yeah I don't actually want to get rid of
my brain immediately but I don't go
that I really don't
but I'm like thinking about that memento
mori reminder of death doing very well
those pictures are looking great we're
just going to do sort of calibration
type scans before we start the next part
you know like all young people I was
immortal at once and like all people of
my present age I noticed growing old and
when I had a stroke five years ago I
really noticed it was an abrupt
discontinuity in my life so this is a
whole brain
you could you could see that there are
two halves two hemispheres you can see
there's the left and the right
hemisphere so the region that we're
particularly interested in
John is the region similar over here the
parietal lobe because as you know
different parts of the brain are very
involved in different functions and of
course that's one of the things why we
think it's so fabulous that we're going
to be able to do functional magnetic
resonance imaging with you because we
want to see which part of your brain is
particularly active when you're thinking
some of your great mathematical thoughts
okay
that's no problem we might be my
answering sort of essentially stupid
questions but not stupid but I mean is
this object here a rotation of this
object in some funny geometrical shape
well I couldn't care less whether it is
enough to know but I was trying to
answer the question I suppose the thing
that made my name was a mathematician
was the discovery of this amazing
geometrical group in 24 dimensions
I distinctly remember at one time sort
of sitting in an armchair lying down on
the floor government Russia exactly what
and for the waving my arms and legs in
there because I needed to be able to
point in more directions than there are
in three-dimensional space you know and
that had more effect than the discovery
of the serial numbers namely it affected
my career I went from being an unknown
to being at the center of the stage for
mathematicians the world stage in a
certain sense
as a magazine may have heard of called
Reader's Digest and in one of these ones
it said are you a tongue gymnast I was a
student in Cambridge at the time and
then they gave for exercises and it said
so far nobody has been found who can do
all four and this sounded like a
challenge to me that we do thick and
thin
over me
even the waves
rather than just staying at the age of
25 which I did for 25 years or beast I'm
aware now that there's only found out
that much to go and it's a very very
different another frightening feeling
you know so this date the 20th of
December approached me you know at the
1st of December it was about three weeks
away and it just inexorably approached
me and grew more and more frightening
looming you know
now it's almost behind me
you
if you'd like to see even more with John
Conway of course we've got the videos
that we've made here on numberphile but
to really get under his skin
we're going to recommend this genius at
play Siobhan Roberts there'll be links
under the video I haven't read it all
yet I've only just got it but I have
been going through it and I'm really
impressed it's really interesting but
also really accessible and fun I think
everyone from a mathematician through to
the layman like me will quite enjoy this
one so have a look if you like and
thanks for watching today links below in
the video description genius at play